in cities across the country people
March to celebrate Juneteenth but this
year's observance has taken on a
heightened urgency as more Americans
demand racial justice Adriana Diaz
reports thousands lifted up their voices
in Chicago Friday many in the memory of
George Floyd it was so heart wrenching
and it seemed to resonate with so many
people that there is a new desire to do
something especially on an anniversary
like this yes from Oakland to the
nation's capitol were a silent crowd
Neal to round the Martin Luther King jr.
memorial it wasn't just a celebration it
was a rallying cry for change but also
understand that the best the very best
is yet to come
in Galveston Texas the city where
Juneteenth started a somber ceremony
replaced the major festival which was
cancelled due to Cove in nineteen there
was also a surprise announcement from
the National Archives in Washington
Friday researchers discovered the actual
handwritten Union General's order
emancipating the Texas slaves writing to
the people of Texas all slaves are free
this year more corporations are honoring
the day with every voice and sing with
dozens of companies including Nike lyft
and Twitter
making Juneteenth an official holiday
back here in Chicago marchers say
they're fighting for their future
to come out if we just stayed home like
lunch that there was a change nothing
would change momentum to recognize
Juneteenth is growing this week New York
and Virginia made it a paid holiday for
state workers and yesterday bills were
introduced in both the House and Senate
to try to make it a national holiday for
CBS this morning Saturday Adriana Diaz
Chicago